نعم ، إذا ألقيت نظرة على خريطة جيك ، فإنها
تعطيك فكرة عن سبب كون هذا
مميتًا للغاية هنا فيغاس ستريب لدرجة أن
الكثير من الناس يعرفون أنهم
يمرون في منتصف كل شيء
يقع مكان الحفل هنا على الجانب الشرقي من
خليج ماندالاي هنا  وهذه
هي الغرفة التي أطلق منها هذا الرجل النار ،
لذا فإن ما كان لديه كان منظرًا مبالغًا فيه حقًا
للمكان بأكمله هنا على بعد حوالي
400 ياردة وكل ذلك بسهولة في
نطاق أسلحته الآن على تلك
المسافة من الأسلحة التي كان يمتلكها
ما نعرفه عنهم حتى الآن ،
ربما رأى كل رصاصة
تسقط من قدمين إلى أربعة أقدام في مكان ما هناك
أدناه حيث كان يصوب ، لكن
لم يكن هذا مهمًا ، لقد سمعت كل تلك
النيران السريعة هناك التي كانت النيران السريعة
موجهة مباشرة نحو الكتلة السائبة  من
الناس أمام المسرح مباشرة مثل
هذا ، لذا فقد كان مجرد إطلاق نار كاسح
حيث لم يكن هناك طريقة للناس
للخروج من الطريق وهذا هو السبب الأول في
أن هذا الهجوم كان مثل هذا الهجوم المميت الكثير
من الناس  في منطقة مضغوطة
يمكن أن يطلق النار على السبب الثاني وهو أن
هذا كان هجومًا مميتًا بسيطًا إلى حد ما ،
هناك سبعة مخارج رسمية
لمنطقة الحفلة الموسيقية ، الأربعة على الجانب
القريب مني كانت أيضًا المداخل التي
سمعناها يتحدث شهود العيان طوال اليوم  حول
الأشخاص الذين يحاولون العودة للطريقة
التي جاءوا بها
نفسياً ، يفعل معظم الناس هذا في
أوقات كهذه ، لذا كانوا في الواقع
يتجهون نحو المسلح وليس بعيدًا
عنه حتى أولئك الذين حاولوا الفرار
والجزء الأخير من هذا سبب الوفيات
و  تصاعدت الإصابات أيضًا إلى
حقيقة أن العديد من الأشخاص لم يعرفوا مكان
إطلاق النار هذا من ضيفك الأخير
قالوا إنها كانت تعلم أنها قادمة من
أعلى ولكن تحدث الكثير من الأشخاص الآخرين طوال
اليوم عن قولهم إننا لم نكن
نعرف أيها  كان الاتجاه قادمًا من
مشاهدتك لمقاطع الفيديو التي تشاهدها أشخاصًا يبحثون عن
جميع أنواع الاتجاهات وفي النهاية
يتجول الكثير منهم في المكان الذي
كانوا يحاولون فيه أن يكونوا آمنين حتى عندما قالت
إنه لن يكون قادرًا  لإطلاق النار عليك
غير مدرك أنه طوال الوقت الذي تمكن فيه المسلح
من رؤيتهم جميعًا هناك ، فإن
هذه هي الأسباب الثلاثة وراء استمرار هذا
الهجوم لفترة طويلة وقتل وجرح الكثير من الأشخاص